do you ever feel like you're turning
into your parents
for these spotted hyenas it's a definite
possibility
hyenas have a matriarchal society
meaning the moms set the social
structure
they live in clans varying in size from
just a few to more than 100 hyenas
where social rank impacts everything
from reproductive success to lifespan
it's no surprise that cubs inherit from
their mothers in the form of genetic
information
but they inherit something else too
their social connections
scientists drew on 27 years of direct
observations to pin down
how hyena social networks transition
between generations
they discovered that mothers pass on
their social status to their cubs
through their alliances with other
hyenas
cementing relationships that remain in
place for the next four to six
years but this pattern doesn't hold up
for low-ranking mothers
and for good reason cubs of high-ranked
mothers tend to live longer
when they keep their mom's alliances
creating a silver spoon effect for the
hyena elites
but like humans not every hyena can rely
on a boost from family legacy
cubs of low-ranked mothers suffer from
following in their parents footsteps
they live shorter lives when they rely
on their mother's connections alone
however lower-ranked cubs can compensate
for their mother's lower status by
forging
new alliances with years of hyena data
in the bank
scientists are already looking for new
research directions
like how hyena fathers impact social
rank and how these relationships compare
with other social species like primates
and you don't have to go far to find
parallels and humans
from college legacy admissions to job
opportunities parental connections can
be
pretty important so if you're a hyena
with friends in high places
it's best to keep them but if your
parents rank at the bottom of the clan
you'll have to make new connections on
your own
you